So glad I’m recording this. But wait, we don't
have to pretend. There's actual real evidence
of things flying around in our airspace that's
way juicier than a fake video. I have feelings
about this lately because we've been deep,
deep, deep in UFO stuff and why the U.S.
military is studying UFOs, which they call UAPs.
Because UFO sounds like aliens. And lucky for us,
we don't have to make up videos because there
are videos out there of really interesting cases
where Navy pilots are flying around and they're
seeing things that they don't understand. They
don't understand how they're moving, they
don't understand what they are. And it's
really interesting stuff. The U.S. military
is releasing these reports and they're kind
of dense and not very exciting to read until
you find the juicy data. But like, it's there,
they're collecting stuff, we're understanding
UFOs. Let's go look at that stuff instead of
having to make, like, pretend videos with,
like, pretty shitty animation. Sorry.